Привіт усім,
мене звати Саша Шевченко,
я викладачка української мови
та літератури школи “Майбутні”.
Сьогодні у нас заняття з
української мови для 8-го класу.
Сьогоднішньою нашою
темою є тема “Відокремлення”.
І для того, щоб розібратися,
ми маємо насамперед з’ясувати,
що ж це за явище і для
чого нам з вами його вчити?
Як ви вже зрозуміли з
самого слова “відокремлення”...
Це якесь смислове, інтонаційне
виділення певного члена речення
для того, щоб надати йому більшого
значення, звернути на нього більше уваги.
Ну і так само з самого слова
зрозуміло, що якщо ми відокремлюємо,
то відповідно нам потрібні
якісь розділові знаки.
Ось для цього і потрібно вивчати цю тему,
щоб ми могли правильно
ставити усі розділові знаки,
зустрічаючи відокремлені члени речення.
І перед тим, як занирнути в цю тему,
нам потрібно пригадати, які
взагалі є другорядні члени речення.
Пригадайте, ви вже це точно вивчали,
а я спробую освіжити це в пам’яті.
Означення — зі слова
так само зрозуміло, що ми
вказуємо на якусь характеристику слова.
Зазвичай означення відповідають
на запитання: який? яка? яке? які?
Обставина вказує на
місце, спосіб, час і умову дії.
І додаток, як завжди кажуть
— це решта, але, насправді,
додаток означає предмет, над яким,
власне, відбувається та чи інша дія.
Додатки відповідають на
запитання усіх непрямих відмінків.
Для тих, хто забув, непрямі
відмінки — це всі, крім називного.
Отже, ми пригадали з вами
другорядні члени речення
і далі я хочу звернути вашу увагу,
що відокремлені члени речення
вживаються не тільки в
якихось старовинних книжках,
а, насправді, ми можемо
зустріти їх і в сучасній культурі.
Ось деякі приклади сучасних пісень.
В першому прикладі “велика і
смішна” відокремлено комами.
В другому прикладі “закладені
кимось ще в ранніх літах”
так само відокремлений член речення.
В третьому прикладі “вставши” є
відокремленим членом речення.
І певно, одна з найвідоміших пісень.
Дивимось на дошку.
В четвертому прикладі “непрочитана
книжка” — відокремлений член речення.
Далі в п’ятому реченні “словом наділена”
так само відокремлений член речення.
В шостому реченні “залишаючись
самотнім серед чорних стін”
так само цілий відокремлений
член речення просто дуже великий.
І ще останні два приклади.
“Прихилившись до тебе”
і “розбитий серед ночі” так само є
відокремленим членом реченням.
Ви вже побачили, що ми часто
використовуємо відокремлені члени речення
і в сучасному мовленні,
і в сучасній культурі.
І так само взагалі
відокремлені члени речення
зустрічаються в будь-яких стилях, в
усіх стилях, по суті, української мови.
Дивимось на дошку.
Але мають різні функції в кожному з них.
В художньому здебільшого ми
вживаємо відокремлені члени речення
для того, щоб надати
образності, метафоричності.
В науковому, офіційно-діловому
та публіцистичному...
Відокремленні члени речення
допомагають нам виділити
головне від другорядного,
додати певну лаконічність,
послідовність і логічність думок.
Ми з вами з’ясували, що
відокремлені члени речення
можуть бути другорядними, тобто
означенням, додатком, обставиною.
Є ще четвертий, але про
це я розкажу вам пізніше.
Ми побачили, що відокремлені члени
речення вживаються в будь-яких стилях,
зустрічаються в повсякденному житті,
що їх точно треба виділяти комами.
Для того, щоб вже перейти
безпосередньо до вивчення
конкретних відокремлених членів
речення, нам потрібно пригадати звороти.
Для того, щоб згадати про ці звороти,
нам в першу чергу потрібно
взагалі розібратися — що це таке.
Відповідно спочатку ми маємо
пригадати що таке дієприкметник,
а що таке дієприслівник.
Насправді, в українській
мові все дуже просто.
В самих словах заховані їхні значення.
От візьмемо дієприкметник...
Це дія і прикметник, тобто ми беремо
дієслово і робимо з нього прикметник.
Тобто маємо зробити дієслово, яке буде
відповідати на запитання який? яка? яке?
Наприклад, написати (який?) — написаний,
сказати (який?) — сказаний,
зробити (який?) — зроблений.
Єдине, що ми маємо назавжди
просто собі запам’ятати,
це те, що в українській мові ми не
вживаємо активних дієприкметників
з суфіксом уч, юч, ач, яч.
Я знаю, що це звучить
дуже складно і страшно.
Активний дієприкметник це
той, який сам робить з собою дію,
наприклад: лежачий, стоячий, біжачий.
Ви відчуваєте, що щось тут не так.
Ці слова ріжуть слух
і, насправді, це калька з російської
мови, наприклад, «бегущая по волнам».
Українською мовою ми не вживаємо
ці дієприкметники, а замінюємо їх.
Найпростіший спосіб їх замінити — це
зробити з них складнопідрядну частину,
наприклад: та, що біжить;
той що летить; той, що говорить і т.
Але інколи ми можемо знайти відповідники.
Наприклад: найрозповсюдженіша помилка, з
якою я зустрічаюся — це слово “оточуючий”.
Його вживати не можна,
ми шукаємо відповідник,
йдемо або простим шляхом
це — ті, що мене оточують,
або – моє оточення, замінюємо на іменник.
Це важливо і це треба запам'ятати.
Далі переходимо до дієприслівника.
Тут так само в самому
слові заховано його значення.
Ми беремо дієслово і щось
маємо взяти від прислівника.
Прислівник — це незмінювана частина мови,
тобто дієприслівник
має теж не змінюватися.
Тому дуже просто, ви
берете будь-яке дієслово
і ставите до нього запитання:
що роблячи? що зробивши?
Так і утворюються, власне,
дієприслівники: сказавши, зробивши,
прочитавши, намалювавши,
читаючи, пишучи, малюючи і т. д.
З дієприслівниками і з дієприкметниками
розібралися. Наступне питання.
А що ж таке зворот?
Дуже просто. Зворот — це
коли є один дієприслівник
або дієприкметник і до нього
додалися якісь залежні від нього слова.
Може буде одне залежне
слово, а може бути купа.
Зараз я хочу, щоб ми спробували
попрактикуватися і
уявили себе редакторами.
Ці речення з першого погляду
виглядають цілком нормально.
В першому реченні виглядає так,
начебто сніг пішов в той
час, коли він піднявся у гори.
Речення абсолютно не логічне.
Бачимо тут “піднявшись у гори”
— це дієприслівниковий зворот.
І обов’язкова умова використання
дієприслівникового звороту...
Тобто у вас дія, яка відбувається в
звороті, має стосуватись вашого підмета.
Як бачимо, підмет “сніг” і він не може
підніматися в гори, а потім сам і піти.
Як краще сказати таке речення?
“Піднявшись у гори...”, якщо це,
наприклад, ми ішли з вами в гори,
“....ми застали сніг”
або “....ми помітили сніг”.
Тобто має бути виконавець дії “ми”
або якийсь інший об’єкт
виконання цієї дії — кого захочете.
Але головне, щоб він відповідав
цьому дієприслівниковому звороту.
Ідемо далі.
Другий приклад.
Тут дуже схожа ситуація.
Воно з першого погляду виглядає, що
такого тут сказано, ніби все нормально.
Але, насправді, логіка порушена.
Виходить так, що
подруга підійшла до Олени
і подруга сиділа ж в цій кав’ярні.
Теж знову повний абсурд.
Ми розуміємо, що в кав’ярні сиділа Олена,
відповідно ми маємо
замінити наступним чином:
Сидячи в кав’ярні, Олена зустріла подругу.
Тобто, таким чином, щоб
Олена була виконавцем дії
ось цього дієприслівникового звороту.
Далі йдемо.
Наступне речення, третій приклад.
Ніби нормальне речення.
В чому ж тут проблема?
Ми одразу з вами маємо
пригадати, що в українській мові
не вживаються активні
дієприкметники з суфіксом уч, юч.
Відповідно нам потрібно
цей дієприкметник замінити.
Підемо простим шляхом.
Зробимо підрядну частину:
“Нам потрібна людина,
яка знається у СММ сфері”.
Або ж ми можемо також “знаюча”
замінити на іменник “знавець”.
“Нам потрібен знавець у СММ сфері”.
В принципі, можна замінити
ще й на “професіонал”,
але це вже трішки інакше
лексично забарвлене слово.
І останнє речення.
Знову та сама історія.
У нас дієприкметниковий зворот
і в ньому вжитий активний
дієприкметник із суфіксом уч, юч.
А що ми маємо зробити?
Ми маємо його замінити, тому що
в українській мові він не вживається.
Відповідно ми залишаємо першу
частину “мене тішить троянда”
і спробуємо замінити —
“розквітла на вікні”.
Це виходить нормальний, адекватний
дієприкметник, який можна вживати.
Я сподіваюся, що ви повністю
розібралися з цією темою,
тому що я для вас
підготувала маленьке завдання.
Отже, правильна відповідь:
“пануюча” замінюємо на "панівна"
“знеболюючий” на “знеболювальний”
і “віруючий”, дуже дивне
цікаве слово, це “вірянин”.
Тобто українською мовою
ось ці три слова є неправильні.
Вони є калькою з російської
мови і їх потрібно заміняти.
Ми вже пропрацювали
увесь теоретичний матеріал,
який стосувався відокремлення загалом
і настав саме час перейти безпосередньо
до відокремленого означення.
Для того, щоб розібратися з
відокремленим означенням, дуже просто.
Згадуємо, ми вже говорили
про другорядні члени речення,
пригадували, що таке означення.
Означення — це член речення,
який вказує на ознаку,
тобто характеризує предмет
і відповідає на питання: який? яка? яке?,
але відокремлене, значить
будуть якісь розділові знаки.
З цим зрозуміло.
Тепер ми думаємо, а чим же може бути
виражений цей дієприкметниковий зворот.
Теж елементарно.
Якщо у нас відокремлене
означення має відповідати
на запитання який? яка?яке?,
відповідно такі і частини
мови будуть його презентувати.
Дивимось на дошку.
Зверніть увагу, для прикметника
і дієприкметника є одне
дуже розумне слово...
Їх називають непоширеним означенням.
Насправді, тому що
там кількість слів менше.
Дієприкметниковий і
дієприслівниковий зворот...
Поширеним означенням,
там просто більше слів.
І інколи в нас відокремлене означення
може буде представлене інфінітивом.
Я покажу такі приклади трохи згодом.
Але ці варіанти трапляються не так часто.
Що нам ще потрібно пам’ятати, коли
ми шукаємо і намагаємося визначити,
чи це взагалі відокремлене означення,
як його ставити, чи
ставити там розділові знаки.
Нам потрібно тримати
в голові, що означення...
Воно ж когось характеризує чи щось.
Відповідно має бути завжди
означуване слово, тобто те,
до якого воно буде відноситись.
Від означального слова
будуть залежати розділові знаки.
І зараз безпосередньо
про них і поговоримо.
Почнемо з розділових знаків у зворотах.
Тут дуже просто.
Можете навіть намалювати
простеньку схему,
може бути схожа на
додавання в першому класі,
коли ми змінюємо щось місцями.
Дивимось на дошку.
В першому прикладі
означуване слово – “книга“,
“написана поетом” — дієприкметниковий зворот.
Як бачимо, дієприкметниковий
зворот стоїть після означального слова,
він має бути виділеним комами.
Зверніть увагу, що зворот
може стояти і в кінці речення,
тобто ми виділили б ще однією комою.
Якщо він всередині, то
ми виділяємо з обох боків.
В наступному прикладі
ми поставили спочатку дієприкметниковий
чи прикметниковий зворот,
а потім поставили
означуване слово, по суті...
Просто змінили їх місцями і від цього
вже залежить, який у нас буде знак.
Якщо ми поміняли їх
місцями, то кома не потрібна.
Але ви знаєте, що в українській
мові часто трапляються винятки
і безпосередньо до
цього правила у нас будуть
декілька винятків.
Звучит страшно, але на прикладах простіше.
Подивимось приклади: “написана
поетом” – дієприкметниковий зворот,
“книга” – означуване слово, яке в кінці.
Між ними є ще слова, тому
ми маємо поставити кому.
Подивіться на наступний приклад:
На столі лежала написана
поетом чудова книга.
Ми бачимо “написана поетом книга”
і між ними стоїть означення “чудова”.
В цьому випадку ми не ставимо кому.
Тобто, якщо будь-яке інше
слово влізло, то поставили б,
якщо ще одне означення —
То не маємо ставити.
Є ще ось така цікава історія,
ви маєте це пам’ятати з теми
однорідних членів речення,
але я вирішила вам у цьому
контексті все таки нагадати,
що, якщо у вас за
прикладом другого речення,
коли означення влізло між
дієприкметником і означуваним словом.
Якщо ми їх змінимо місцями, то
ми між ними будемо ставити кому.
Дивимось на дошку: “на столі
лежала чудова, написана поетом книга”.
Це є просто однорідні члени речення.
Але після “поетом” стоїть
наше означуване слово
і ми не поставили кому,
тобто виділяти не потрібно.
І останнє правило на виняток.
Дивимось на дошку.
В чому суть.
Насправді, ви можете
це речення переробити,
поставивши в ньому
запитання: чому? і сполучник “бо”.
Дивимось на дошку.
Коли дієприкметниковий зворот має відтінок
причини, ви його маєте виділити комою.
Спробуємо зробити завдання.
Зверніть увагу, речення майже однакові,
тільки в них змінений порядок слів.
Шукаємо наше означуване
слово і дієприкметниковий зворот.
Бачимо означуване слово “картина”,
яка? “намальована майстром”.
Пригадуємо, якщо у нас іде зворот,
а за ним стоїть означуване
слово, то ми кому не ставимо.
Відповідно перший варіант є правильним,
(але ми маємо переконатися
і перевірити варіант б) і в).
У варіанті б) означуване слово
“картина”, яка? “намальована майстром”.
Послідовність дотримано, означуване
слово, дієприкметниковий зворот,
виділили комами, все правильно.
Наступне речення, варіант в).
Шукаємо означуване слово “картина”,
зворот “намальована на стіні”,
між ними влізли інші члени речення,
відповідно ми маємо виділити його комою.
Тому дійсно правильно
ми обрали варіант а).
Ми поговорили про
розділові знаки з зворотами.
А тепер, що нам робити, якщо це не
зворот, а просто непоширене означення?
Пригадайте, непоширене означення —
це дієприкметник чи просто прикметник.
Відповідно тут є одне головне правило,
дуже впливає на це
правило послідовність слів.
В першу чергу, у вас має
бути така послідовність.
Я вам озвучу це правило, ви
почуєте наскільки воно страшне,
але, коли ми перевіримо його на реченнях,
ви впевнитесь, що,
насправді, все дуже просто.
Одиничне означення —
це тобто по одному означенні.
Розглянемо перше речення.
Шукаємо тут означуване слово — “вечірка”.
Дивимося, перед ним є
вже одне означення “крута”
і далі йдуть ще означення одиничні,
просто це однорідні
означення “весела і драйвова”.
Відповідно після “вечірка”
ми поставили кому.
Тепер подивимося, якщо у нас уже
була порушена ця послідовність слів
і ми перед означеним словом забрали
означення і перенесли його наперед.
Або взагалі можемо його прибрати.
Подивимось на друге речення.
Відповідно всі означення
стоять після означуваного слова,
комою їх виділяти не потрібно.
Є кома після “крута”, тому
що це однорідні члени речення.
І ще один варіант, коли ми
теж змінюємо послідовність слів.
Третє речення.
Що відбувається тут?
У нас ніби іде означуване
слово “вечірка”,
купа іде потім означуваних
слів, але знову ця історія,
в середину щось влізло.
Якщо в середину щось влізає,
ми маємо наші означення виділити
і вони стають відокремленими означеннями.
Спробуємо перевірити.
Дивимось і шукаємо
означуване слово і означення.
“Дощ” - це означуване слово і ось
наші означення “молодий і веселий”.
Як бачимо, між ними влізло одне слово,
а ми знаємо, якщо щось влазить, ми
маємо наші означення виділити комами.
Тобто після “шумить” ми ставимо кому.
Значить цей варіант неправильний.
Розглянемо варіант б).
Подивімося, у нас тут
означуване слово “дощ”,
перед ним стоїть ще
одне означення “весняний”
і далі ми ще хочемо дати йому
характеристику “молодий і веселий”.
Якщо у нас виходить, що перед
означуваним словом вже стоїть прикметник,
ми далі маємо виділити комами.
Тому тут кома потрібна.
Відповідно цей варіант теж неправильний.
Скоріш за все в) варіант залишився
правильний, але ми маємо перевірити.
Подивімося: “дощ”, далі ідуть
означення “молодий і веселий”.
Перед «дощем» немає ніякого
означення, ніщо не порушено,
відповідно ми не маємо тут ставити кому.
Цей варіант дійсно правильний.
Ще один лайфхак, який має
допомогти з розділовими знаками
при відокремлюваному означенні.
А саме, якщо у вас означуване
слово виражене займенником,
хто не пам’ятає, що
таке займенник, нагадую -
це частина мови, так само, як ми говорили
з дієприкметником і дієприслівником...
Все зчитується з самого
слова, “замість іменника”.
Тобто це частина мови, яка називає
предмети, але не називаючи їх імен.
Відповідно, якщо у вас означуване слово
виражено займенником,
то ви завжди будете виділяти його комами,
де б не стояло ваше означення,
чим би воно не було виражене,
ви завжди будете ставити кому.
І так само буде відбуватися, якщо ваше
означуване слово просто взагалі випущено.
Подивимося на прикладах.
В першому прикладі означуване слово “я”
і виражено воно займенником
і далі йде означення “крута”.
Ми маємо виділити його комами, тому
що означуване слово у нас займенник.
Розберемо друге і третє речення.
“вона” ми замінили слово “книжка”.
Ми бачимо, що означуване
слово виражене займенником
і нам байдуже тут порядок слів.
Чи ми змінили місцями, поставили
дієприкметниковий
зворот спочатку чи в кінці,
це не грає великої ролі,
тому що тут основне, що в нас
займенник — це означуване слово.
І останній приклад.
Тут випущене означуване слово взагалі.
Тут немає “я читаю
книгу”, тобто воно відсутнє.
Відповідно ми все одно
маємо поставити кому,
де б не стояв наш
дієприкметниковий зворот.
І останнє правило, яке ми маємо знати
про розділові знаки при
відокремлених членах речення — це тире.
Було б занадто просто,
якби у нас були тільки коми,
має бути і тире.
Тут у нас три випадки вживання.
Перший — це ми хочемо надати
певної експресивності, підсилення.
Ми ніби в самому реченні, у
нас іде таке наростання емоційне.
Дуже часто тире вживають
автори, письменники в своїх творах.
Пам’ятаєте, на початку я говорила,
що у нас інколи відокремлене
означення може бути виражене інфінітивом.
Нагадую, інфінітив...
Це першопочаткова форма
дієслова (робити, писати, читати і т. д.).
Відповідно ось якраз наш випадок.
Читаємо третій приклад.
Перед нами завдання яке?
- відшукати істину.
Як би воно дивно не
звучало, але це є означенням
і воно стоїть у кінці та це теж
додає нам причин виділити його.
Але насправді, “відшукати”- це інфінітив,
який позначає в нашому
прикладі відокремлене означення.
Відповідно ми маємо позначити тире.
Ну що ж, наше заняття
вже підійшло до кінця
і яке ж заняття без домашнього завдання.
Наше заняття завершилося, робіть
домашку і чекаю вас на наступному.
Бувайте!